each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's it is my pleasure to introduce re
one REE is a fourth-year PhD student at
Indiana University Bloomington his
research is focused on system security
including ecommerce security side the
channel issues privacy-preserving
techniques and reverse engineering of
binary executables he has been the lead
author of many papers in top-tier
security conferences including Oakland
CCS and you sneak security and this
summer he is doing his third internship
with us here at MSR and the work is
going to present today started as his
second internship last year it is about
how can you shop offer free online so we
thank you for coming to my talk this is
a joint project between Indiana
University and Microsoft Research the
other authors are certain chef on one
and sheds career you know research we
did several interesting processes from
web stores such as this DVD show here
and this agility cream I guess this is
for bodybuilding not not to cost you
yeah at the interesting because we did
not pay for them or we only paid with
the arbitrary price we found a set of
logic bugs from the checkout mechanisms
of the web stores besides buying this
kind of free stuff we do have our series
or connect academic motivation which is
to study the API as a web service
paradigm we know that today a lot of big
websites expose their web services
through such a fob api's such as
Facebook
people amazon ec2 etc so a lot of
websites cause us ap is to integrate the
sort of party services now the whole
system consists of the web client so
integrator website so service API
website I can give an example here the
web client maybe it's a browser and the
integrator website is liked by calm and
service API website website is people so
by the common integrate people and
something like that is sort of party
service integration our integer is that
the security for such a multi-party web
apps can be very challenging of course
as seasonal researcher our goal is to
show a significant empirical evidence to
support the intuition ah in a in a Maha
partisan error from the security angle
we have to consider what you've one part
he is not he just like the kid suppose
the three parties can only communicate
through 11 phone calls so kita can tell
mom a story x and tell dead a slightly
different story x prime so even if mom
and dad communicate if they're not smart
and careful enough the kid will have a
good chance to get something that he
does not deserve so this is the
intuition and concretely we study that
today's web stores which integrate the
third party casual services such as
people amazon payments and google check
home we call them kesha as a service or
similar case this scenario is very
important because today a lot of web
stores are using cast services just the
name of you here now the web store only
handles the other information and the
case handles the payment so the whole
system has to make a joint decision
which is whether the shopper has made as
a proper payment or to the other here I
want to give you some basic knowledge
about the Cheka workflow at this side
you see the familiar checkout page of
the web store and the other side that
you see the three parties which is the
shopper so just to web store such as by
com so case such as people you also see
the web api's exposed by by the two
websites so when the shopper is ready to
check out it clicks the checkout with
PayPal button this will generate a HTTP
round trip this consists HTTP request RT
1 dot dot a tube 8.com and the HTTP
response which is RT 1 BB from buy com
RT one that be will redirect the browser
to people where the shopper will see the
payment confirmation page so the shop
will confirm the payment by clicking
this panel button these were generated
our history delay and paper then
collected the payment may communicate
with Beckham then responded with our
history Dhabi Arthur adobe reader acts
as a browser back to buy com where the
shopper cities order completion page
sorry
yeah you have any reservations please
yeah so in this process you see that the
show press browser user redirected back
and forth between the two websites but
this is just the one example there are
many other payment methods such as
people standard Amazon simple pay Google
Checkout etc and that even for one
payment method different web store may
integrate it in a different way so
basically we have a lot of this kind of
scenarios to examine the problem is what
do you think that the shop at the
shopper has to run browser to do all of
these communications actually the
shopper has the complete freedom he can
play with any of these messages because
all of the API is I exposed to the web
so under this Arabic assumption can the
shopper shopper for free or set up she
reprises then we study that source code
of the popular merchants of software
such as no commerce interspire much in
the software as a software used to build
web stores like a knob commerce and
interspire they are powering tens of
thousands web stores on today's Internet
we also study the Amazon SDKs which are
used by the web stores to integrate
amazon payment services in addition we
we study the popular big store gr 0 and
x com but we don't have the source code
we start them in a black box fashion
what we found is nine different check
house in errors vulnerable to a set of
logic box and the as a result we can add
a shop for free or set yourself
determine prices do so that the time
limit we only
talk about three of the clocks in this
talk also know that we only talked about
the high-level summaries of the of the
box and there's some south or east in
the source code critical but cannot be
covered here Chris Reda wallpaper to
understand that a complete story we only
talked about so I mean from the high
level what's the was that is kind of
seems to look like all the cool crowd
source besides yeah we either we first
study that the open source merchants of
software and also some commercial muchin
software to actually taste a source code
which there can buy the source code yeah
and also we studied at those big stores
which we do not know what what's the
scholars are using then we studied that
Frissora should be harder gay or dirt on
you not I think without source code
access you cannot thoroughly check what
kind of problems they have but by
because by using the experience we gain
from the source code analysis and also
by reading the document the like pipe or
provided it with lurking understand more
about the traffic not just look at the
playing traffic you actually have a lot
of contacts yeah
the first case is about the merchants or
software no commas integration of Amazon
simple pay this is the figure of the of
these kind of communications back and
forth and also the merchants of STAR the
logic and that this figure is a little
bit of complex this is the show in the
paper and but let me charge I me let me
try to give you a simplified story
because that is the kind of a little bit
complex and cannot be talked about this
figure here a a simplified a story can
be start from the benign shoppertrak who
want to buy a DVD from the web store
Jeff Jeff will composer sign the letter
and ask a Chuck to forward to Amazon to
do this payment the letter says dear a
muzzle order 1 2 3 is the ten-dollar
when it is paid coming at you for 25 11
12 to 22 so Chuck were just forwarded
this letter and Amazon then verify his
signature and ask a check to do this
payment then cause a phone number and
Jeff where they ship the product the
phone number here use the analogues to
the return URL actually all of these
communications are HTTP or HTTPS they're
just HTTP messages and that this
scenario is more or less common sense
similar to real life purchase but in the
online world anyone can register amazon
seller account so can chuck so what we
what we did is to purchase a $25
mastercard gift card this there is some
kind of I mean this type of gift card
which is called mastercard and also you
can also purchase visa gives it harder
and this kind of gift card we purchased
up by cash and we didn't show our real
identity so we found that with you
registered we first registered register
the car and
the named Max meets with the fake
address and phone number then we found
that this kind of mastercard gift card
can be used to register for sell
accounts in in order cast services so
shopper Chuck also plays marcella Mac he
tells Jeff that I want to buy this DVD
and Jeff will give him the same same
ladder now instead of folding this
letter to Amazon Chuck replaced the
signature with Max signature because
China has the signing of signing ability
of Mark and for a module he only sees
the other often of marc has nothing to
do with Jeff after the payment he is
done amazon caught a number but the
number actually the recipient is jeff so
so for Jeff he indeed it has a pending
order which is one two three and he
verifies the signature which is indeed
amazon signature so Oh amazon does not
link the signature with the phone number
or HTTP address signature it's any
signature and it goes and you can visit
with any phone number not anyone yet the
phone number is in the message 'i and is
protected by the signature but amazon
does not guarantee that that this this
phone number is you could actually a
marxist phone number patient so here the
message society by
and it is always designed by us but
there is no linking hear what you were
saying is the link between
return the wire and the previous the
signature on the previous as you which
is now our signature that's missing yes
music
so Jeff does not end this way that
Amazon will send him a notification
which is completely irrelevant because
Amazon essentially says to Jeff that
Chuck just made a mark Chuck just pay
the mark ten dollar for his order 123
and the chief will finally ship the
product so in this case emblem thought
that chuck was buying from mark but Jeff
thought that chuck was paying to Jeff
and this gap caused the problem the
second case is about the merchants of
software intersperse the integration of
paper express again this is the figure
of the communications shown in the paper
let me try to give you a simplified a
story suppose we can only have one
shopping session which is for this chip
holder or the ID 1 and this is the
sketch of the communications as shown in
the previous slide the the most
important messages are history Derby
which is a intro website every direction
in the the interweb statutory direction
we are called the API update order in
which the store attached argument at the
ID order ID 1 and the signed by the stop
T star denotes of designing so the
shopper can also temper with it and
honestly shopper were just do this
redirection but let's see if we start a
secondary shopping session this this
time we place an expensive order or data
to we will skip the payment step the
interesting thing is we still can get
our history Derby in which there is
order ID to stand was a star so the next
thing is pretty simple just copy and
paste is value to RT for the eye of the
first session will release this message
and in this way we can check out the
expensive water from the faucet session
so the third case is about to interspace
integration of google checkout
high-level summary of this bug is the
the payment total is calculated at the
moment of RT to da che that is when the
shopper clicks the checkout button and
the the other is created as a moment of
artistry delayed as is when they show
her clicks pen out by them so there are
two moments and between the two moments
the chakra is allowed that you add more
items so then things become simple you
just the place that ship hiding in the
shopping cart then you click the
checkout button then add more items and
click the Pay Now button this way you
only pay for the cheaper a cheaper
violent and you check out the entire cut
we confirm all of these vulnerabilities
in the robot info levels we first
install the NOC commerce and industry on
our own web server we used our own sell
accounts and by all accounts too we
successfully to the other text in
despair has a famous hosting service
which is called a big commerce we
created our own store on ecommerce and
successfully confirmed that these
attacks and and and we really want to
tell end to end the story which is the
malicious job can really go to the real
wood shop for free by exploiting this
kind of logical box so we found the real
stores powered by an OP commerce
interspire this kind of stores and we
check it out physical goods and
downloadable goods for free with less
pay off for free mmm and then besides no
commas interspire we're also curious
about those web stores whose source
codes are not available to us can we
still find a similar box because we
cannot thoroughly check their logics so
we studied as a popular store by the
coin gericom we were able to show that
we
a source code access some extra ideas
are still applicable we did o.o sir what
did you need to modify in terms of
software to pose as it as the attacker
so you're running the web browser right
where all these reductions are going too
quick what part what part of that
software or the the stream that was
being communicated that you have to
modify in other words you have to modify
ie to launch this attack or Mozilla to
launch this back corner actually you
have some tools to use like you firefox
you have some kind of traffic monitoring
tools you can monitor the traffic and
also you may use some kind of HTTP proxy
or something which you can hijack the
traffic you can modify the traffic yeah
you actually you don't have to modify
the browser you have a lot of us are
done without modifying the we're all
gonna modify and in process these are
two jewels what is Firefox but in which
responses and in some other cases and
across principles
I take it with clothes all sides not
only do not have the sword didn't even
have the object file of vaccine you can
either songs donor or no object or XE
uh no no source code and no what no bj
you know we exceed no and she didn't
have any binary you could actually
reverse engineer
you have this the direction the two
edges look better communications
we did other experiments responsibility
first they were under the clothes
guidance of Indiana University lawyer
insured we well we were not doing some
crime and we've got the support from the
ding of our school and we ensured the
following principles no intuition to the
websites and no monetary loss to the web
stores when we got the product whereas a
return the product or we painted the
owed money and that will communicate it
all the details to the effective artists
that the outcome is quite pleasant
because no party expressed as a negative
point on what has because we're really
helping them they have the park and that
we would have them you have this bug you
should fix right so and most of them
actually appreciate it our responsible
fruit is it possible feet you can take
your lease in anyways you could actually
fix the issue yourself or is it voice
required that the software providers
headed provided things it is either the
webstore have to do a fix or eat and in
some case maybe the service provider
needs to fix because you know
auto-attack he's like a tag pass as long
as you find the points that you can
block this pass then you actually fix
the problem so he's either I the
webstore can fix the logic or the
service provider to something yes yeah
the cast yeah Kashia services yeah
amazon published security advisory in
which is a creditor me and the
interspire even asked if I'm interested
to doing a security auditor work
afternoon that I found for
vulnerabilities in shikahr Magnusson's
and our research was has been covered by
a lot of news articles and which are all
positive about what how we conducted
this research
we communicated to other details with
affected parties I think this one with
the bark on customer service is a pretty
interesting after we check out a product
for free we send this message tell them
that one order was not paid so bodycon
responded with a generic message telling
us turns just all the possible reasons
for delay the charge of party cuts all
the possible reasons so it's a
misunderstanding because the payment
method was people same we sent Senna the
second message turns I'm PhD student
doing security research and reused us at
how can I mean we leased this kind of
details and say the replies based on our
record will be on the purchase stage so
we had a dis difficulty to convince pero
con well the money sometimes this type
of attacks we believe is not easy to
notice by the company assistance of the
web stores and we finally returned as a
product after 45 days that's a refund
editable period because after that that
day they will not refund us we just
retired there were not to start a refund
process then we disclose the order
technical details and that they finally
fixed the bug he's instead of industry
how much the salary did it costed to do
this paper for you I think they would
much rather you stole the I do
mmm and this is the status of bug fixes
in this process most parties were very
responsive and the good news is all the
box has been fixed a recently but like
if you a shopper may not be a good news
because you can never go to this website
shop for free and a particularly
interesting one is the MSD Kevin ability
now I did not describe it in this talk
it actually affects almost all the web
stores which is support emergency amazon
payments service 15 days after our
report amazon released a new search of
SDKs covering all the five programming
languages to support and they publish
the security advisory in which they
require all the web stores to upgrade to
the new SDKs within 40 days so this is
pretty serious bug we also studied at
the complexity of the café's the checker
logic which is skipped in this talk
specifically we manually extracted a
subset of the check our logic of the
openness fire and then we use the power
which is developed by Microsoft Research
a single one of them major developer
UCSC sitting here and we use the power
to do the verification and there we
measure that complexity of the check our
logic
when we talk to some as to verification
researchers somehow some of them said
that protocol verification tools would
have discovered that these kind of bugs
automatically so what is exact executive
contribution of this work actually the
real problem is not how how to check how
to check a formal model such as a
protocol against a set of security
predicates this is not a real problem
the problem is there is no protocol to
adjust the web programs and the the real
farm heart like ninety percent of our
research time was on starting this kind
of assistance understanding the
operational assumptions of these systems
and the accurate security goes and
without such a clear understanding we
can only say that a given a perfect tool
for more formal model or formal protocol
and a given accurate a predicate you
using the verification technique king
you can rediscover these bugs so the
real challenge here is not how to check
but how to extract as a larger model and
the watch to check which is weather
system researchers major contributions a
metaphor can be the the end-to-end
problem here is to find a path in the
real world the verification is a
technique to solve the reach ability
problem between two points on
well-defined map but we neither in such
fun a standing of the real world in
order to georgies at shorter useful map
and where the person who enjoys a map in
conclusion we showed that my party web
apps are fundamentally more complicated
than traditional to party web apps from
fortis from the security sense some
complexities include a confusion in
coordination concurrency week bindings
advisory play multiple roles we
empirically prove that can space the web
stores are under imminent threats and
also due to our research we also believe
that web service integration may become
an important area to apply formal
reasoning testing approaches the key
challenge is how to extract the model
and the defying our security braddock
aids currently we only studied as a
regular check how scenario and that
there are many other important check out
in error such as a subscript
subscription a marketplace gift cards I
believe these are very good research
opportunities also the integration of
other web services facebook linkedin
allow the other websites to access its
users data again you see the similar
three parties in arrow here and also
Google Yahoo treat her allow the other
websites to authenticate users for them
we actually had some encouraging
progress along this direction we really
appreciate people from Microsoft and
Indiana University for the help on this
research without them that the research
cannot be possible thank
for any other questions
3comments one is the old USSR head store
where you stood four times in line
because the cashier end with money and
an assist are handled goods and maybe
towards checking how they did it yes sir
because we have the Western moment
models that you know the same guy takes
the money gives you the goods the
Russian were way too bureaucratic the
other is have you read a programming
Satan's computer program Satan's
computer by Ross Anderson say because he
expressed one principle that you always
named the parties involved don't assume
don't let the crypto persuaded come from
a or from your seat name it and across
secure it and and you take a look at how
red tape was used for real it with
English documents yes if people the red
tape has become a very bad word what you
used to do was you cut hold you punish
hose and documents you ran red it takes
to it you put a waxy no runs two ends of
the tape so you could neither you could
remove doctor you will not interpolate
new documents in there was something you
need to do tie two documents together
and
and you did not now we need to get the
logic equivalent of that yeah where is
it so I think probably similar
is that God does provide some primitives
I of course you can find it to documents
if I calibrating them and the finest
division but the art here is how do you
apply these messages here which one
should be the defining should happen
between which box where those are not
thoughts as clean
so that the show has a decent primitives
are there for half your step
the question so let me this on the head
if you were working at an Amazon and you
want to determine how secure your
payment system is or it contain a means
of our weaknesses how would you go about
doing so by working amazon I think maybe
we can go back a little bit like we say
here the web service integration may
become important area and the case based
integration is is one of these kind of
service integration so I think we wish I
should be really interested in this kind
of formal reasoning or testing
approaches which are to see that if
these kind of techniques we incorporate
these techniques to really ensure that
there is no problem but this is just a
one technique because like if a module
provided is a kind of payment service
actually he is hard to ensure that the
webstore that logic is is correct and so
he I think he should also spend a much
effort to help those web stores to to
correctly to integrate the service and
while efforts may be providing security
conscious guidance and also provide some
kind of automatic tool which can help
check their logic if the logical is
correct yes
you see not just half as long as
probably yeah it's non technical problem
it's also across with cost organization
for example yeah yeah he's across
organizations but it's about the
interaction of calls from different
organization right now so thing the
other thing is kind of coming out which
is the law of some shins are being
manually liver called our never fully
understood every frigid sort of the
flashlight what what is the technique
here to solve these problems or are you
merely exposing that these problems
exist and what's the solution just wrong
the solution was you have you have found
that this kind of box then this surgery
is very simple you just fix them I mean
if you you have you know this bug
disease right yeah Riley from right to
you said okay i spliced this new water
idea into my url scream but yeah that
still isn't isn't that a legitimate
request like I mean how do you
distinguish that from malicious how do
you distinguish between two URLs one of
which is malicious of course you copy
this better another one would be exactly
you know you intended that to be there
to be ordered you to be the signature
and so on I'm trying to get is how do
you differentiate these two URLs to be
one is malicious
right so far from you from the game I
knew there was a problem there was a
cell binding that's been
it's like a time of check time of use
for anything 50 so I think the key here
is good threat modeling and looking at
kind of what you pointed out what your
goals are what are the assumptions are
making and
the help us interact
but it certainly does get complicated
when we're talking about four apartments
really
Prince to the cellar and the cashier
service they have to get background
acquitted they have to understand each
other much better and yeah yeah because
ultimately your user the shopper it will
be given some code or you know some kind
of JavaScript all right or it is going
to open a web page provided by yourself
in any logic that does all these new
establishing https channels getting URLs
if you directly over us and whatnot so
your shopper isn't writing any of that
school what you what you said is that
you modify that stream right if you
modified it in some malicious way yes
you use the proxy or something but you
haven't really gone the next step
whereas if you were really very
malicious bad God you would change all
of the code that is running on your
machine the user right what if you could
actually write the damn browser from the
start to end and then talk to yourself
the seller and and get the response and
change it in any way shape or form and
then redirect to the rubber so there
could be many more malicious things yeah
yeah and I think in cancer research
what's really done is we don't even have
to to change it like that the browser
side of logic or something we only need
to manipulate those that have back and
forth I mean that the communication with
the web store the communication with the
cash and we don't even need to check a
change this kind of maybe a set of
logical order to the web browser we
didn't even do that and we we still have
such power and that if we consider their
part maybe are more possibilities you
expose the bus and the bus will be fixed
by better integration
but then there is a soul whole second
class of threads which you know if you
don't assume this kind of use the word
benign but i think is a similar
complicity malicious browser right yeah
if you have anything components there
then then do you think the solutions the
solution that you're posing where is
teller and the the cashier service have
to get better integrated of the visit
does those solutions be able to thwart
this problem if your attacker becomes
much more malicious and he can change
many more things
we say he's asking the bug fixes that
were made for these claws would they be
valid bug fixes even if the attacker
model was way more adversarial yeah i
think that the fix is just a we tell
them this Park and then they find a way
to block the attack attack pass so to
think they fix the problem so I think
it's it so it didn't have the no
guarantee you go you're blocking sorry
just got dealt a pass English the answer
should be in fact even at this moment we
are assuming the
the most malicious and religious there's
there's no logical she'll decide
whatever I receive item I can completely
let suppose anything we can just assume
all
the message field so I don't know
whether there is anything which is more
malicious and that because we we have no
no logic we can do everything on the
black side so what you're saying is you
are allowing for that kind of threat
model so you are assuming a perfectly
capable adversary that can change it and
everything at its jen yes or yes but
sometimes being this kind of Fatah
temporary
fiddle across proxy sometimes it neither
firefox parking here i said that's the
tech
just understand circle make it clear
there's no reason why these problems
cannot be solved in fact this is not an
impossible so practice writing a piece
of code that proposes transactions alive
sister one way to look at this is just
that it's a pre-employment ation of the
software that is to the vents
transactions
well maybe poor design endpoint in
vintage thank you yes absolutely I
thought but that's like what you've just
said can be applied to all pieces of
software yeah i agree walk for all bugs
are like that right then well no no
actually disagree but there are problems
for which you cannot solve that's it so
i can give you an example of problem or
the internet the large and you want
strong consistency with high I'll
apologize i remember a calculus one is
wrong okay so but this problem to me
seems like we could solve there's not in
this not impossible promises so problem
just a
a case of Pakistan
it's not impossible but but the thing is
when you consider what
the complexity that you have to deal
with and the scope how many how many web
source out how they're so that maybe
it's practical individually you might be
able to solve and create one specific
scenario that might be nearly one
hundred percent perfect perfectly secure
that is very hard to say that it's
absolutely secure and then when you take
all stores together shopping systems
it's nearly impossible to secure the
ball
so another questions